ever thought your gta5 could look a bit
snazzy oh well have no fear and eagerly
anticipated mod is finally here I'm Lucy
and welcome to your 4k textured GameSpot
news updates gta5 Redux the impressive
Grand Theft Auto 5 mod that overhauls
numerous aspects of the game's PC
version is at long last available to
download created by Josh ROM Ito the
ambitious mod enhances the game's
visuals adding a new weather system 4k
textures visual effect and more the
video from YouTube channel ocean powell
serves as a launch trailer for the mod
and runs down a lot of what it offers
you can also see a full feature list on
the mods official website and needless
to say it's incredibly impressive it
also modifies numerous other areas of
the game it adjust the wanted system
tweaks the way weapons work changes
vehicle handling introduces new wrinkles
to the way police and pedestrians
operate and adds a whole lot more but
with GTA 5 not officially supporting
mods the process for installing redux is
unfortunately not as easy as it could be
before starting the process you'll need
to make sure you have been clean install
with no existing mods as a tutorial
video you can watch if you need a visual
walkthrough Redux has been a long time
coming it was meant to launch sooner but
was postponed at the last minute when
its creator was hacked back in August
you can download the mod for yourself at
the link below but as always be careful
about doing so from sources you don't
completely trust so are you gonna
overhaul your Los Santos still waiting
for that single player DLC I know I am
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I met Lucy James
games and for more on gta5 make sure you
keep in games whoa